want to start with something a little
different today we have been talking for
a while about the idea of universal
basic income and whenever we talk about
universal basic income invariably we
also hear about some tech billionaire
that likes the idea of universal basic
income and we wonder anytime that we
hear about someone who is in such a
position of power that is for or against
some policy or idea we wonder well what
is it that motivates them to take that
position is it the good nature and
empathy and humanitarian Drive of tech
billionaires that has made some of the
notable ones say they support universal
basic income or is there more to it we
recently interviewed Andrew yang who's
running as a Democrat for president in
2020
he's running primarily on universal
basic income and we had a very good
conversation with him about ubi and he
didn't seem particularly concerned that
rich tech guys mostly as as they are
effectively are in favor of universal
basic income or at least didn't seem to
think that there were any self-serving
reasons for that and I've sort of
floated the idea that if you are Jeff
Bezos at Amazon or you are Mark
Zuckerberg at Facebook just to take two
specific examples and you imagine
everybody in the country getting an
extra $10,000 right some kind of ubi of
about $800 a month or $10,000 a year
people without that much extra money who
get an extra 10 grand a year are very
likely to spend that additional money on
stuff stuff like the products may be
sold on Amazon or may be stuff like the
products advertised on Facebook so
that's a possible motivation for some of
these tech billionaires to say I would
love to give people another $10,000 to
have which will become mostly spend
money on products because these are not
people likely to be saving a lot of that
money so let's put that aside for a
second but let's remember it let's now
talk about a related topic activism we
spoke
last week maybe the week before about
sort of the concept of approved and
acceptable activism and it was related
to the heckling of politicians and the
concept of sanctioned and comfortable
activism and as I've said before if you
were only going to be activists using
the tactics that those in power say are
okay you're unlikely to ever really get
anything done so the similarity here
would be tech billionaires and
politicians who say we want change we
want to improve the world etc except
only within the confines that they have
established and are comfortable with
that's the one important element that
underlies both how tech billionaires
want to change and improve the world and
how politicians want to encourage and
support activism so let me give you an
example when tech billionaires encourage
and approve of universal basic income
they support changing the world via
universal basic income in a very
specific way that's not going to disrupt
the broader status quo and it's going to
keep the infrastructure basically the
same and this is outlined in a really
good article in The New York Times by
Anand Anand Giridhar das I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly called beware
rich people who say they want to change
the world what he outlines is that
giving ten thousand dollars to everybody
in the United States their universal
basic income changes nothing about
corporations being able to use loopholes
to pay no taxes it changes nothing about
the corporate lobbying industrial
complex that allows corporations to have
broad control over our political system
it doesn't do anything about eliminating
the carried interest loophole which is a
great tool for them to use to pay very
very little money it's not fake change
like universal basic income is a real
change and the ten thousand bucks a year
would be really great to a lot of people
but it is safe change that mis maintains
the status quo and doesn't endanger the
infrastructure that the corporate tech
billionaire elites
have built to benefit them right because
in most ubi plans now that money is
coming from money that we're currently
spending on social welfare programs so
things like food stamps Medicaid instead
of spending in that category where
there's a lot of bureaucracy we'll just
give the money directly to the people
now you could fund ubi by raising taxes
on the rich but that's not so
politically savvy and that's why we
don't see too many of those plans out
there sure but I think if you're a tech
billionaire you would probably be
willing to even if it did require paying
a little higher tax that's a pretty fair
trade for maintaining the exact status
quo system that has allowed you to
become a billionaire to begin with right
so now let's talk about the political
side politicians say let's raise the
minimum wage to $15 or $20 or let's
lower it to $10 or let's argue about the
effect of a higher minimum wage on
fast-food workers but basically what
they're all saying is let's keep the
system the same and argue about the
details which are 10 11 12 13 14 or $15
minimum wage business charity ok
business charity is another one where
you you see activism via donations
cheered but it's actually not going to
change the big picture of how the elites
and billionaires and corporations
control government and control
politicians so this is why I am more
steadfast than ever that we need to
decide the type of change that we want
we need to decide which protest methods
are appropriate and when right now I'm
not saying heck up heckling Sarah
Huckabee Sanders at a chicken joint
changes the status quo that that's not
what I'm saying it's not about the
heckling of Trump officials specifically
but the point is anytime you let them
set the rules it means the game will
never change you will be arguing about
exactly where the strike zone is rather
than actually changing the game that's
being played to use a sort of sports
analogy and right now really if you want
change you have to disrupt the status
quo that is where this sort of
fundamental discomfort or skepticism
comes from when you hear me say I
support you bi universal basic income
but we need to
understand why it seems to be so
appealing to so many tech billionaires
it doesn't mean that they're bad people
but we need to understand that a lot of
these movements it's sort of it's a
control I don't like to use the term
controlled opposition but it is an
arbitrarily narrowed scope of activism
you bi- income tax for example as a
discussion
neither changes the system that has
allowed corporations to come to
completely subjugate subjugate and take
over control of our political system
that i think is the key point to keep in
mind here today's show was made possible
in part by sion games and their new game
for phone and tablet called antidote
which is an award winning strategy game
it's all about using vaccines to defend
the human body from bacteria and viruses
it's fast paced the graphics are amazing
the game has actually been commended by
the World Health Organization because it
has a mission to fight back against the
anti vaccine misinformation so the game
is educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off a deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video